hey youtubers it's Charlie and the
Walking Dead is back it literally picked
up moments after the mid-season finale
it was a huge tunnel ship from that
high-octane attack you can think of that
episode more as like a walker buffet and
this episode is like the desert a
hundred and ten ounce jar of pudding
dessert quick announcement though I'm
doing a weekly giveaway in all my review
videos it's gonna be a $20 Amazon gift
card all you have to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment I'll just
be picking a random winner and I'll
announce that in my Q&A video that I'll
post tomorrow careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet but I'm
gonna start with my top 5 moments and
then I'll do my review so everybody grab
a spoon and get some of this pudding
number 5 Michonne eulogizes Hershel in
my mind she just went back to the prison
to see what had happened since that
mid-season finale and happened upon
Hershel she wasn't only looking for him
in a way though she did give him the
final piece that he deserved it was
really touching giving what the governor
did speaking of which we actually
finally saw that gunshot wound Greg
Nicotero actually ended up bringing that
animatronic Hershel head to talking dead
remember that time on talking dead when
Chris Hardwick tried to feed pudding to
that dead Herschel head so wrong number
for Karl almost has to kill Rick next to
Karl getting buried beneath the pile of
walkers this was one of the most intense
moments in the episode which is why I
chose it over to the other close calls
the Carl had watching Carl just break at
the thought of having to kill his dad
was so horrifying we could actually been
making those wheezy walker sounds the
entire episode he was so beat up he
looked and moved like a walker to this
fake-out moment was really just the
payoff to that I kept thinking there
were walkers just around the corner
wherever they were but it was always
just Rick making those sounds number
three missions flashback dream sequence
this was the most beautifully shot scene
in the episode
Michonne had really reverted to her
season 3 personality you know the coping
mechanism of just shutting everything
down and taking pets the dream sequence
was just her way of processing what had
happened and I don't know what would
have happened had she not known about
Carl and Rick's footprints if he didn't
catch the reference though those two
walker pets that Michonne had at the
beginning of the episode were just
visual metaphors for Mike and Terry you
know the men she'd lost number 2 Carl
finally has it out with a comatose Rick
I think having Rick passed out the whole
time sped Carl up to that breaking point
where he could just verbalize all the
things he was angry about yes he did say
some very awful things but he wasn't
actually mad at Rick
at least not in the way he made it sound
he's just expressing all the rage and
frustration that's built up over the
past three seasons all the friends and
family they lost you know their entire
way of life being destroyed this has
really been my favorite scene with the
two of them together they've had a
couple of moments together this season
but none that were this intense just let
it out Carl just let it out it's okay to
cry and my number one moment
Carl gets his victory pudding this was
Carl's big moment of triumph you know a
big reaffirmation he said I win twice
during the episode and this was the
second time everyone had lost so much
that the chalk on the door and that
pudding on the roof was just a way for
him to take something back to get at
least one big win I mean seriously
Michonne had this amazing trip you know
back to reality but this was a really
Carlos episode what is his future though
is he going to end up turning into
someone like me shown she did just knock
on the door at the end of the episode
and Rick said you know it's for you so
clearly he's going to be spending a lot
of time with her it was such an amazing
episode though let me know what your
favorite moment was as a midseason
premiere I have to give this a solid a
you know largely due to Chandler Riggs
being so awesome in it in the deep dive
into Michonne which we haven't gotten in
a long time
the story was a direct adaptation of
issues 49 and 50 of the comic book two
the story is always informed by the
comic but this was actually a literal
beat for beat adaptation Herschel's
funeral was a great payoff to the fandom
I had so many questions on my Walking
Dead videos since episode 8 about how
Hershel would totally be a walker it's a
sentence that's worse than death so it
was really nice to see him laid to rest
speaking of which it was really nice to
finally get an answer on the governor a
lot of people bet me that he would
totally show up as a walker but when we
saw the gunshot wound in his head we
totally got our answer I was a little
disappointed that we did not get to see
baby Judith Robert Kirkman actually said
we would get a definitive answer about
her very soon Nicotero actually did
imply that we would see the governor
again before the season finale but
obviously knowing what we know now he'll
probably just be a hallucination I can't
say enough about the stylistic choices
in the episode though when we shown was
mowing down her herd of walkers the
camera panned out you know to reveal
this neat little circle it looked just
like the dead night's Watchmen's circle
that the white walkers left for Jon Snow
during season three of Game of Thrones
great story great style it's really
gonna be hard to top this next week the
good news is is that we will pick up
with the groups we didn't see in this
episode so I am crossing my fingers we
will see baby Judith
I'm posting my Q&A video for this
tomorrow so ask me any question you want
about this episode or the rest of the
season
I'll also be announcing the random
giveaway winner in that - after this
episode I am so pumped about the rest of
the season though right now click here
for my top 10 predictions and click here
for that Q&A video I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight
high fives